c'était le temps du vélomoteur et des
cibiche des usines grise bruyante où
régnaient les contremaîtres les petits
chefs
le travail était harassant c'était aussi
le temps des utopies porté par les
étudiants par cette génération née au
sortir de la guerre qui rêvait de
changer le monde
alors quand au début du mois de mai le
quartier latin s'enflamma femmes la fac
de caen se mettent en grève par
solidarité âgées manif débat étudiants
et enseignants conspuent une société
corsetée il proclame bientôt l'autonomie
de l'université
ils ne veulent pas d'un savoir soumis au
capitalisme
la fièvre gagne les usines à cléon c'est
le monde à l'envers
les ouvriers de renault prenne les
commandes l'occupation durera cinq
semaines
le 13 mai un seul mot d'ordre de grève
générale à caen dix mille manifestants
serre les rangs
dans le seul département du calvados
on dénombre 40 mille grévistes mais le
rtf regarde d'ailleurs le havre célèbre
sa nouvelle reine et dans les campagnes
le cidre cool comme si de rien n'était
les nouvelles sont filtrées télé
normandie montre aussi les files
d'attentes aux pompes à essence tout un
pays est à l'arrêt
wavre les dockers tiennent le port dans
les usines occupées les ouvriers oublier
un temps les cadences la surveillance et
se prennent à rêver à des jours
meilleurs
prenons nos désirs pour des réalités
disait le slogan
de la joie de la rage ces sentiments
mêlés s'exprime encore dans la rue ar -
le drapeau rouge est hissé sur la statue
napoléon
mais une autre france perd patience et
prend peur
en ce week-end de l'ascension sur les
planches de deauville
l'air est suffocant chacun attend
l'issue des négociations ouvertes à
paris au lendemain des accords de
grenelle
les comités de défense de la république
organise la riposte
le 30 mai à quand le drapeau tricolore
flotte sur la foule
ce défilé préfigure le raz de marée
gaullistes aux élections à venir
le mois de mai qui prétendait courir
devant le vieux monde est bien finie
même si plus rien ne sort jamais tout à
fait comme avant